monsieur benillouche bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
la droite et le centre ne sont pas
tombés d'accord sur le budget de l'état
c'était prévisible selon vous oui
c'était prévisible c'était prévisible
parce que ça n'a jamais marché
la d league ans a voulu essayer d'éviter
les élections le 2 mars est en fait
compte après les élections du 2 mars et
en fait quand il n'a pas réussi parce
que benjamin netanyahu n'a jamais joué
le jeu là dans ce cas là de dire soir il
avait accepté de signer un accord de
coalition
mentionnons la le vote d'un budget pour
les années 20 21 et là il a refusé de
voter son vote et de voter ce projet
donc on sait que c'est de la volonté de
natanyahou de ne pas signer cet accord
et d'essayer d'aller aux élections mais
ce qui est pris que ce qui était prévu
et tout à fait différent aujourd'hui
parce que la situation a totalement
évolué par rapport à la période des
élections du 2 mars
la gauche a complètement explosé le la
droite a complètement explosé il y à une
recomposition totale de ces deux parties
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé je
dirais aux élections françaises ou là la
gauche est complètement inexistante
les travaillistes n'existe plus en
israël et le parti de deux baies digue
ans a explosé en deux entités une entité
propre je dirais pro propre coalition
avec bibi et une identité anti coalition
mais là ce qui est nouveau c'est que les
lélés l'épée les opposants internes au
parti du likoud ont décidé de quitter le
likoud et ça ça va faire mal parce que
le belge guy dana est un légitimiste ina
en 2005 lorsque toutes les gens tous les
députés avaient quitté le likoud pour
aller avec avec ariel sharon lui est
resté et il est resté avec ses 12 maigre
députés parce que c'est un légitimiste
c'était quelqu'un qui est attaché
à son parti si aujourd'hui il a décidé
de quitter c'est parce que la coupe
était trop plein et que bibi n'a natale
et on n'a rien voulu faire pour lui
alors moi ce qu'on se pose comme
question c'est comment un homme
politique aussi avisé que natanyahou ait
pu laisser en roue libre
un de ses opposants il aurait pu tout
simplement lui octroyer 1 lors de la
dernière organisation de la coalition
les aurait pu d'octroyer un ministère un
ministère même difficile pour qu'ils se
cassent les dents
eh bien il a laissé en dehors et quand
on est en france justement conséquence
un de ces de cette dissolution de la
knesset
les israéliens vont donc se rendre aux
urnes en mars prochain
en moins de deux ans à la quatrième fois
qu'ils vont voter comment est-ce qu'ils
réagissent face à sète à cette annonce
eh bien on peut dire que les et les
israéliens sont là c'est sûr lassé de
toutes ces élections qui n'apporte rien
mais les trois premières n'ont rien
apporté parce qu'ils aiment pas eu de
changement je pense que cette fois ci c
4e vont évoluer vont faire évoluer la
situation
parce que nous avons une heure une
scission à droite nous avons une
scission à gauche
par contre ce que je pensais que les
israéliens risquent d'être déçus de la
peau de deux guides et hop ça parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas montré
officiellement mais on le sait que
certaines c'est un opposant certes mais
c'est quelqu'un d'extrême droite
il est contre les élèves contre les
vaincus création d'un état palestinien
il est pour le développement des des les
implantations il est pour l'annexion
eh bien on s'aperçoit enfin de côte
qu'on va changer de bord et qu'on va
prendre quelqu'un d' extrémistes à
droite et là c'est là où la déception va
se faire sentir
parce qu'on pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui est qui est très simple on le voit
très ouvert mais sa politique depuis
l'âge où il avait 18 ans et où il est
rentré dans un parti qui s'appelait
karelia à l'époque et bien
ç'a toujours été un homme de la droite
de la droite
et donc c'est pour ça que je à l'heure
actuelle des gens de gauche le
soutiennent parce qu'en fait ils sont
pour tout sauf natanyahou mais il risque
de se réveiller trop tard quand ils vont
voir que la politique qui est faite
ça va être une politique dure une
politique anti palestiniennes anti-arabe
je dirais même et qu' ils vont tout d'un
coup s'apercevoir que nous avons à faire
un extrémiste de droite
bon eh bien c'est le choix ça va être le
choix c'est pour ça qu'à l'heure
actuelle on attend ces élections qui
vont peut-être faire ressortir ses
problèmes internes qui vont faire
ressortir les problèmes de chacun des
candidats est peut-être tout le monde
attend d'israël le messie c'est à dire
l'homme qui va pouvoir sortir du lot
pour créer la surprise
pour l'instant merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup jacques benillouche d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste indépendant